Hey wise, crack timing can be weird.
When we started working on this video about V for vendetta,
we really didn't expect its release to feel so eerily timely.
The film is obviously not a perfect or even close metaphor for this moment V the
leader of the protest movement to picked it in the film is extravagantly violent
in real life.
Overwhelmingly peaceful protests continue in the wake of the brutal murder of
George Floyd by the police. We hope that you're making your voice heard.
We also hope that you're able to do so safely and that you take care of your
mental health during this difficult time. Thanks guys.
Hey, wisecrack, Jared here today,
we're talking about the vaudevillian veteran cast vicariously as both victim and
villain by the vicissitudes of faith. It's V for vendetta.
The film based on the graphic novel of the same name was met with generally
positive reviews and relative box office success. But the graphic novels,
curmudgeonly creator,
Alan Moore was left unimpressed by Hollywood translation of his work describing
the film as a deep fanged version of the original. So is Alan Moore, right?
Or just very grumpy at detective comics.
Let's find out in this wisecrack addition on V for vendetta deep or dumb,
and of course, spoilers ahead for the film and the graphic novel.
Our guys let's do a quick recap.
We start out with a news monologue delivered by the voice of London,
Louis [inaudible], who explains the current state of affairs.
A mysterious plague has spread across the world,
turning the United States into a leper colony.
And now 20 years later is what the world's biggest Napa colony and
provoking radical changes in Britain led by dictator Adam subtler.
The far-right Norse fire party has transformed Britain into a police state that
runs on complete obedience and conformity while a combination of state
propaganda and secret police managed to keep most of the country compliant with
seller's authoritarian regime. One man rises up to oppose it. The,
the film follows V and his ward slash not totally consensual mentee, Eby,
Hammond as V blows up symbols of British law and assassinates party members who
have wronged him.
But these final masterpiece is a revolution itself as is very calculated.
Acts of terror inspire the masses to rise up against their fascist leaders.
Let's first start with what the film and graphic novel have in common.
These fixation on symbols, whether he's talking to lady justice,
blowing up symbols of British authority or wearing a guy Fox mask,
the guy seems to see symbols as a key to cementing political authority,
rather than just the violence of Jack booted men.
The antidote to those symbols are counter symbols,
ideas and art as Evie reminds us.
To tell the truth while politicians use them to cover the truth.
And his shadow gallery is basically a Noah's Ark of outlawed ideas.
The film even takes some of this farther as EVs friend Dietrich hides a Koran
and protest art. He also gets all Benny Hill in his mocking of subtler.
[Inaudible].
Even as Dietrich is dragged away by the secret police and VI dies.
It's clear that their ideas will outlive them, but while this conceit is plenty,
[inaudible], it's not like more, the film have really reinvented the wheel here,
maybe dramatized it. Well,
this brings us to a small choice in the film that ends up drastically during its
meaning of the North fire party comes to power in the movie and like many,
a real life authoritarian regime,
North fire presents the idea of a glorious more homogenous past the country has
lost by deviating from traditional values. Britain once had a strong,
proud national identity they claim,
but it has been diluted and polluted by modernity diversity and sin using a
swastika like red and black symbol,
which includes the Christian Cross North fire presents itself.
As the antidote to chaos. Sutlers motto is strength through unity,
unity through faith or strength through purity, purity, through faith,
as it's phrased in the graphic novel,
which also explicitly links the motto to the Roman fast.
She's a bundle of wood that cannot be broken unless divided this simple forceful
slogan continually reinforces the notion that the country is strong when
everyone lines up behind the leader and lives, according to his rules,
consequently,
anyone who does not offer complete obedience is an enemy of the people.
The pursuit of personal freedom becomes an attack on the very fabric of society.
This country back into chaos at a glance,
this anti-authority and tales seems like exactly what Alan Moore would hope for
from a cinematic adaptation of his work. So what's his beef.
So much of Moore's identity as an artist has revolved around interrogating the
idea of power and how it's used in particular has worked is largely about the
dangers of any one person wielding great power, whether they're naked,
blue superhumans like Dr.
Manhattan or oppressive dictators like subtler or Susan,
as he's named in the book while director James McTeague adaptation holds true to
the rejection of authoritarian.
The issue more found was that it makes it all too simple.
The film's world is separated clearly into evil tyrants and virtuous rebels.
That much of the graphic novels nuances lost Moore's V for vendetta was not a
clear cut case of good against evil,
but a battle between authoritarianism and anarchism by contrast.
And the movie is just authoritarianism versus honest people that brings us
Norris fires rise to power in the graphic novel,
a global nuclear war between the Soviet union and the United States in the
eighties has reduced much of the world to an irradiated. Wasteland.
Britain is spared by the war, but finds itself in a state of crisis.
Afterwards when the resulting nuclear winter causes a famine out of the chaos
that follows the North fire party rises to power in the movie, however,
a viral pandemic, rather than a nuclear war lays the groundwork.
This new plate kills thousands in Britain,
and it's reported to have all but destroyed the U S as in the book,
a crisis creates opportunity and the North fire party is able to seize control.
At first glance. This might seem like a superficial change.
The point in either case is that a period of global turmoil creates widespread
panic and leading the British public to turn to a zealot like subtler fear
followed by apathy has allowed the country to fall under the spell of a
right-wing strong man as VI explains fear.
I got the best of you, but in your panic,
you turn to the now hi chancellor Adams.
However, it's later revealed that the virus,
which ravaged Britain was in fact intentionally released by settler and his
cronies to force the country into accepting their leadership.
Know virus, the most terrifying virus you can,
and very much in the you and you alone, nothing.
The point is that in the films version of the story,
the British people were essentially duped Norse fire didn't rise to power by
winning the honest support of the masses foot by fooling them,
contrast that with the graphic novel,
in which the Wars that devastated the world were real,
many of the problems were real.
And the public was all too willing to turn towards fascism racism and homophobia
V for vendetta was born out of Moore's own experience of life under someone whom
he considered to be a hard-right zealot, Margaret Thatcher,
having watched the iron lady when the support of his countrymen more was under
no illusions as to how popular these politics could be. The film, however,
makes the populace significantly less blameworthy.
The people are basically good.
Turning a three book graphic novel series into a two hour movie was always going
to require some streamlining.
So we can't really blame them for cutting out some of the fascist propaganda or
entire scenes,
but far more concerning the movie arguably loses the moral ambiguity of the
graphic novel in Morris telling the government officials who send people to
concentration camps are also people with families, desires, ambitions,
jealousies, et cetera. They're three dimensional. In contrast,
the film reduces North fire to a cabal of cartoonish villains in a dark room,
simplifying the moral and political implications of the story.
Fittingly the movie show seller mostly as a big brother S ominous talking head,
rendering him, literally two dimensional.
He's no longer the complex weirdo who falls in love with a computer from Alan
Moore's version. The film's message becomes this.
There's a small set of clear bad men amongst a sea of good people.
All it takes is one brave hero to help overthrow them and things can be set
right again, in the graphic novel,
the North fire members are of course still awful,
but they're at least presented as fully rounded human beings ranging from true
believers in Norse fire, xenophobic, creed,
to those who are just following orders.
The graphic novel actually takes pains to show us the private lives of these
North fire members,
people who go to church and raise families and goof around at work.
The point of course is not to say that these are good people within this fascist
organization, just that they are people reducing them to comic book.
Bad guys might be more comfortable for the viewer,
but it shies away from their reality.
And just as North fire leaders have been exaggerated into one note, bad guys,
the himself is noticeably softened and simplified for the big screen in the
movie, V is an egg frying,
slow dancing charmer with a love of romantic movies and Shakespearian plays.
He kills in cold blood. It's true,
but as victims are so outlandishly awful that this never seems like too much of
a moral compromise.
The movie may claim that the monstrous things that were done to him turned VI
into a monster, but that's not really what we see in the graphic novel. However,
V is considerably less dashing the mask he wears isn't just to cover his scars,
hide his identity, or create a symbol.
The static unfeeling face it presents is a representation of who V is trying to
become. And the guy Fox grimace sneaks its way into panels of Norse,
fire members suggesting these method isn't so far removed from the people he
wants to destroy because his victims aren't all painted as cartoonish villains
were forced to reckon with the extreme cost of political violence like subtler.
He's ultimately a man.
So convinced of his own ideology that he'll do whatever it takes in pursuit of
it. So what we have is not a battle between forces of pure good and pure evil,
but between a proponent of authoritarianism and an agent of anarchies.
So let's talk about anarchies perhaps the biggest change to these character lies
in what he actually wants at the beginning of the movie,
before the old Bailey courthouse explodes,
he delivers a speech which outlines exactly what he hopes to achieve.
It is to Mme. Justice, that I dedicate this concerto in honor, of the holiday.
She seems to have taken from these parts and in recognition of the impostor
that's stands in her step.
V turns himself and specifically his mask into a symbol of true incorruptible
justice in doing so.
He hopes to remind people that such a thing can still exist if they come
together and fight for it, he tips his hat to the statue of lady justice,
as he does.
So acknowledging both what she stands for and how those values have been
corrupted by settlers brutal and dishonest machine. Ultimately,
he is pledging loyalty to the concept of justice itself.
The V of the graphic novel also has a conversation with lady justice,
but it plays out quite differently.
We begin by making a formal introduction between the two of them while voicing
both roles.
This might suggest that he's not quite so mentally composed as his onscreen
counterpart from the start.
Their conversation is filled with odd sexual undertones framing, lady justice,
as V's childhood crush,
things then quickly turn nasty as VI accuses her of cheating on him with Norris
fire's leader,
painting himself as a jilted lover with a score to settle V is established here
not as a noble freedom fighter coming to the nation's rescue,
but as a deeply damaged man with a thirst for vengeance that borders on the
erotic,
perhaps what is most telling about the scene is that it echoes an earlier moment
in which North fire's leader outlines his racially pure vision for Britain's
future and explains his belief in fascism. Just like with these conversation,
what begins as a statement of political ideology quickly descends into an angry,
personal diatribe with the unsettling sexual undercurrent after lamenting the
fact that he's never been with a woman in real life,
Susan moves on to personifying his political ideal fate as a woman.
He is in love with just as VI does with lady justice while V and subtler are
polar opposites in the film,
the novel uses these scenes to draw an eerie parallel.
Both men are driven by personal grudges and primal desires.
What's most significant though is how the conversation between V and lady
justice with V cutting ties to Liberty and pledging allegiance to anarchy.
Instead, he talks about his dream of turning Britain into the land of do.
As you please,
the name taken from a children's story by Enid Blyton in his view,
the complete obliteration of government and law will allow everyone the freedom
to live their lives. However, they see fit.
The dangers of anarchism are not lost on more, however,
with no government to enforce the laws that are in place,
it's also possible that we enter a Darwin, a state,
or those with the greatest capacity for violence rule over those around them.
Although this isn't exactly different than your life under Norse fire.
Vee also has a term for this, the land of take what you want,
but the chaos can give way to a kind of anarchic order where people voluntarily
submit to the ideals that control their behavior.
This argument is near and dear to more a self-professed anarchist Moresby,
even in folks,
the German word for order or knowing which evokes the system of rules used by
self-governing Amish communities, but in the film,
any ideas of anarchy ultimately disappear except for a quick allusion to a
misquote of the famous anarchist, Emma Goldman.
Without done single cell revolution, not.
Worth having. And a man yelling
what's important is that the graphic novel ends with no clear answer as to where
things will go from here, V is dead.
And while he successfully blows up number 10 Downing street in one last act of
defiance, it's unclear what effect this gesture will have on the nation.
At large, the film's ending is much more of a crowd pleaser while V still dies.
His final act has clearly inspired the country around him.
The sea of guy Fox masks watching on as Westminster burns are proof that the
British people have woken up to the true nature of the North fire party and are
ready to take back their country. The bad guys are dead.
The good guys won authoritarianism as the novel understands is not something
that arises because a small group of evildoers hatch a plan,
it rises out of the country itself championed by large sections of the public.
The movie sidesteps the difficulty of this truth to provide a brighter breezier
version of good conquering evil.
Ultimately the movie is considerably less deep than the source material,
but it still has enough substance to save it from a full dumb verdict.
It cleverly depicts the way authoritarian governments control their citizens by
manipulating the flow of information and offers some interesting thoughts about
the power of symbols in our society.
So pretty deep and maybe important formatively.
If you're a teenage Jared in the end, we're left with the same question,
which V poses to the people of the UK.
Do we want an inspiring story about good triumphing over evil?
Or are we ready to take a harsh look at where that evil comes from in the first
place? Let us know which thing in the comments.
Big thanks to our awesome patrons for supporting us hit that subscribe button
and as always, thanks for watching guys. Peace.
[Inaudible].